e aí agora que o ronaldo você e nem tá
tá tá teto do atingimento bem bacana eu
sempre pego no twitter a syngenta é um
vídeo que você queria que eu fizesse um
dia tá pelo dia estava na nossa vida lá
não sei quem fala de como você perdeu
sua virgindade a fala do que você pensa
virgin da então tá bom com beleza e
tantas pessoas quanto você desistir eu
vou fazer um vídeo sobre o dia que eu
perdi minha virgindade
foi assim no peru ensino médio cursando
técnico em informática e você sabe que
todo custo que a pessoa faz a pessoa tem
um tempo ela tem que fazer um estágio
pagam as horas de estágio da ação 50
horas e toca tem que ser que todo dia um
lugar está gelada como se você tivesse
trabalhando aqui o lugar que eu fazia
estágio era muito longe na minha cidade
que moravam tinha olho se não tinha
população suficiente para dar o ônibus
levava a galera por lula e como é que eu
ia ter lugar a hummer é você sabe que
uma que obama que a orientação é que o
vamos ver como ele quiser trabalhar é o
homem quem está só 60 mil
eu ia saber quem sabe que o estádio está
cheio de espírito de bicicleta aí eu
chegava um lugar de estado em troca por
um portão se botar medo escrito lá de
dentro para não roubar e só que ela é
pior pelo alarme se quer ver que a itown
de quem era essa visita é sair de quem
era era minha bebê falou sérvio era
porque eu já tô levando viu aí para a
guerra agora bicicleta mercado pelo
portão e engorda lá dentro ia passar
mexer aí um dia fiquei me mexendo demais
na internet é ficar mexendo demais e tá
mexendo muito baixo quando fui ver e eu
fiquei sozinha dentro longa trancaram é
o lugar da tabela esperta trancada
baseado que como eu passava base pb ea
única saída que tinha uma escada o hepta
escada olhei para bicicleta olhei país
cada colheita a bicicleta falei meu
irmão eu vou subir com essa bicicleta
minhas costas não vi foi com
inteligentes ao fei inventor de subir a
escada pé da lan a vail pedalando subir
no degrau subiu degrau subir o degrau do
be marrom marrom tem gente por foi um
sétimo de grau meu pé deslizou do pedal
gente quando foi no 7º degrau meu pé
deslizou do pedal de bicicleta voltou
desce a escada eo tatá besser largando
na cell outro toda celebração da
bicicleta entrou mal no meio desse tanto
aquele que foi a virgindade toco na ou
discutir a explicar a minha primeira vez
ela foi assim foi foi uma coisa que eu
não digo eu digo mágica um dia eu digo
perfeita assim maravilhosa o formato foi
tipo assim foi forma boa estratégia
porque é o seguinte quando você nunca
fez todo mundo que fala a vocês se faça
na cara tem um dedo na minha primeira
veio também de ser um é a pessoa fala
assim não poderão ficar são negócio é só
você não ficar nervoso
a peça fala não ficar nervoso pessoa não
ficar nervoso como se fosse um botão na
i fala meu deus eu tô nervoso fala me
preparei para isso clicar aqui
passou não existe quando você está bem
você está e só uns três anos atrás o
dominical da minutos paga foi dormia na
foi dormir foi dormir também inclusive
até sonhando geral 'supermando' super
nintendo quando a disputa se acordei
olhei pra cima a menina de calcinha e
sutiã em cima de mim olhei pra ela disse
bhutta que pai eu quase nenhuma desgraça
vem me acorda a mulher começou a tirar
minha roupa eu falei fala meu deus agora
tirou minha blusa falei meu irmão é
agora tirou minha casa falei meu irmão é
agora o quarto que a gente estava
escutava o pai dela mocana no quarto ele
falou ontem domingo é agora eu estou eu
para fazer assim agora
e ela não não é se refaz toda noite e tá
dormindo disse meu filho eu sei que ele
está dormindo agora convenceu paulo que
no primeiro turno que um homem fez um
negócio amoleceu quais criam um útero na
hora certa nem todo mundo se aquietar o
homem colocou de novo caso fico quer
disse bora bora bora e agora dessa vez
vai
foi no negócio levantar malanje
traumatizou e sabe que se ele tem vida
própria a 0 para a alemanha que amy já
no vasco era segura honra eliminou
hammam banho gazeta chega bem em casa
querem já no ralo para segurar a ponta
com laurene jonny aprovado eu ia pra
baixo eu conversei com ele e colocar 7
de março passam todo dia do preston
indica que a festa não hoje não quero
fazer isso comigo nunca
não adianta nos desse dia não prestou
marcou foi o outro dia prestou deu certo
quando deu certo é muito bom eu vou
entrar em detalhe com vocês aí galera
espero que vocês tenham gostado do vídeo
e também espero que vocês tenham
entendido que a única coisa que quis
passar nesse vídeo foi tudo que
aconteceu engraçada minha primeira vez
se você gostou do vídeo clipe gostei no
youtube até no facebook clique em curtir
que achava engraçado que mostrar algum
amigo que marca o seu amigo aqui nos
comentários no twitter da rtp1 foto
divulgação o instagram curso quem quiser
seguir o instagram também é esse aqui ó
muito obrigado a assistir o vídeo está
aqui eu nem e erland tango aceitam e
caiu